Transcriber: İlker ÖZBAŞ
Gözden geçirme: Ebrar Batmaz
Gel benim sarı tamburam
Sen ne için inilersin
içim oyuk,
derdim büyük.
Ben onun için inilerim.
İçim oyuk, derdim büyük,
ben onun için inilerim.
Koluma taktılar teli
söylettiler binbir dili
Oldum ayın-ı cem bülbülü.
Ben onun için inilerim.
Koluma taktılar perde
Uğrattılar.
Bin bir derde..
Ayın-ı Cem Gecesi nerde?
Ben onun için inilerim.
Yar onun için inilerim.
Göğsüme tahta düşerler,
durmayıp beni okşarlar
Vurdukça bağrım deşerler,
Ben onun için inilerim.
Gel benim sarı tamburam ey.
Efendim, tabibim cananım yar yar yar,
Gel benim sarı tamburam,
Dizler üstünde yatıram,
yine kırıldı hatıram,
Ben onun için inilerim,
yar onun için inilerim.
yine kırıldı hatıram.
Ben onun için inilerim,
yar onun için inilerim.
Sarı tamburadır adı,
Efendim, tabibim cananım yar yar yar,
Sarı tamburadır adım,
göklere ağar feryadım,
Pir Sultanımdır Üstadım,
ben onun için inilerim,
yar onun için inilerim.
Pir Sultanımdır Üstadım,
ben onun için inilerim,
yar onun için inilerim.
Çok teşekkür ederim.
Hepinizi aşk ile selamlıyorum.
Yıllar önce Adıyaman'da
bir konser vermiştim.
Konserden sonra yaşlı bir teyze geldi,
boynuma sarıldı
ve bana Kürtçe bir şeyler
anlattı.
Oradan birisi de çeviri yapıyordu.
Teyzenin söylediklerini.
Tabi bu çeviri bana çok soğuk
ve anlamsız gelmişti.
Döndüm dedim ki biz burada hal diliyle,
anlaşıp hal diliyle konuşuyoruz.
Ne gerek var böyle bir çeviriye?
Üstelik teyzenin elinin sıcaklığı
annemin elinin sıcaklığıyla aynı.
Sen bu sıcaklığı, bu güzelliği,
bu duyguyu
hangi dille, hangi sözcüklerle
anlatacaksın bana?
Evet, gerçekten de Anadolu’da böyle
bir dil var, hal dili.
Ama öyle her an, her yerde
konuşulmaz bu dil.
Önce Pir Sultan'ın içi oyuk, derdi
büyük diye tarif ettiği bu
bağlama çıkar meydana.
Gönülleri bağlar, birler.
Ondan sonra haz dili bu güzelliğin
üstüne bir gül gibi açılır.
İşte ben bu dilin konuşulduğuna
çocukluğumdan beri tanıklık ediyorum.
1971 yılında Erzurum'da doğdum.
Dağın yamacında elektriğin
olmadığı bir köy.
Akşam karanlık çökünce gaz lambası
ve bağlama devreye girerdi.
Türküler, hikayeler, masallar derken
evler olurdu, ışıl ışıl.
gözümüz, gönlümüz açılırdı.
Böyle bir ortamda bağlamayla ne
zaman tanıştım hatırlamıyorum.
Hatırladığım tek şey bu sazla
benden daha güzel
dokunana yakın olabilme isteği.
Bu arada bazı evlerde pille
çalışan radyolar vardı.
Bu radyolardan ne zaman bağlama sesi
duyulsa bütün köy orada toplanırdı.
Birbiriyle konuşan, konuşmayan herkes
o anda aynı duyguyu, aynı heyecanı yaşar.
Arif Sağ, Ali Ekber Çiçek, Âşık Daimi
gibi ustaları işte bu vesileyle duymuştum.
Onlara yakın olmak için
hayaller kuruyordum.
Kurduğum bu hayalleri de
köyün hemen yakınından geçen trenlere
bindirip İstanbul’a yolluyordum.
Gel zaman git zaman
1981 yılında
o trene bindim.
3 günlük bir yolculuktan sonra
İstanbul'a vardım.
Burası İstanbul, kocaman bir şehir.
Alışması pek de kolay olmadı benim için.
Uzun zaman arkadaşlarımın güldüğüne
ben ağladım
benim ağladığıma onlar güldü.
Tabii belli bir zaman geçince alışmaya
başlıyorsun,
alışmaya başlayınca
hayallerimin peşine yöneldim.
Bağlama dersleri aldım, sonrasında uzunca
bir konservatuar dönemi.
Burada çok kıymetli hocalarım oldu.
Hepsinin bilgisinden, birikiminden
istifade ettim.
Bana hayali bile zor gelen büyük
büyük eserleri
bu vesileyle, kolayca çalmaya başlamıştım.
Sonra bu eserlerin sayısını çoğaltarak
bu sandalyeyle tanıştım.
Sizlerle tanıştım,
alkışlarınızla tanıştım.
(Alkış)
İşte her şey böyle keyifli, keyifli devam
ederken
bir arşiv elime geçti aşıklarla ilgili,
günlerce dinledim.
Her aşıktan başka bir duygu, başka bir
dert, başka bir koku, başka bir nüans
geliyordu bana.
Sanki doğadaki bütün güzellikler o
nüansların içine gizlenmiş gibiydi.
Toprak kokusu, çiçek kokusu.
Kuşların çığlığını duyuyorum.
Ustaların sazında ve sesinde.
Fakat elindeki notalarla ustaların
parmaklarından dökülen o güzel nağmeler
bir türlü birbiriyle örtüşmüyordu
tam olarak.
Hani Davut Sulari diyor ya,
diyar aynı diyar da
kullar değişmiş.
Bizimki de o hesap.
Türkü aynı türkü de derdi değişmiş,
kokusu değişmiş.
İşte ben bu değişimin üstüne
biraz kafa yordum.
Ve anladım ki bu nüanslar sadece notayla
değil,
biraz da duyarak, dinleyerek,
koklayarak ve yaşayarak
öğrenilir diye.
İşte o gün bu kokuların peşine
düşmeye karar verdim.
Şimdi aldığım o kokulardan bir tanesini
sizlerle paylaşmak istiyorum.
Hüseyin Orhan Dede ile derleme
çalışmasındayız,
kendisinden bir mersiye
örneklemesini istedim.
Bir dörtlük okudu.
Sonra gözlerinden şıpır şıpır
yaşlar dökülmeye başladı.
Nedeni belli.
Kerbela’nın acısı, Kerbela’nın feryadı.
Hatta Kerbela’yı hatırlatan
bütün mazlumların acısı var o göz yaşında.
Dede biraz sakinleşti.
Kendine gelince bana şöyle
bir açıklamada bulundu.
Dedi ki, biz köylerde evlerimizde
uzun uzun muhabbetler ederdik.
Bağlama eşliğinde gahi saz gahi söz.
Her şeyi buradan öğrendik. Böyle öğrendik.
Dilden dile, kulaktan kulağa,
gönülden gönüle.
Birbirimizi okuyarak, birbirimizi
dinleyerek olgunlaşır, pişerdik.
İsterdik ki çocuklarımız da
gelsin bu okulda okusun.
Pişsinler hayata karışsınlar.
Fakat çocuklar çok istekli başlamazlar da.
Tabi zamanla alışırlardı.
İşte alışıp çalışmadıklarını
bu mersiyeleri okurken onların
gözünün içine bakarak anlardık.
Bir damla gözyaşı döküyorlar ise
ben derdim ki,
bu yaş bu çimeni büyütür.
Günlerce dolandı başımda, beynimde.
Bu yaş bu çimeni büyütür, bu yaş
bu çimeni büyütür diye.
Sonra baktım ki bu yaş
benden de dökülüyor.
O zaman bu okullarda okumaya devam.
Şimdi size bu okullardan getirdiğim
bir küçük Bergüzar var.
Bakalım ne diyeceksiniz?
Ne acayip dumanlıdır başımız.
47′ye yüz döndürdü yaşımız.
Kerbela cengine döndü
işimiz.
El-aman bir damla su seher yeli
Kerbela cengine döndü
işimiz.
El-aman bir damla su seher yeli
Evet bu da Ruhsati’nin derdi.
Bakalım devamında ne söylemiş usta?
Kerem eyle Medine’ye varasın.
Arzu Halim doğru dosta sunasın.
Varsın Ruhsati’yi eller kınasın.
Akıyor gözünden cu seher yeli.
Evet, burada gözden akan cu
Farsça, ırmak anlamında
damlaya damlaya ırmağa dönüşen bir dert
ve Ruhsati bu derdi
deftere yazmıyor, kağıda yazmıyor,
kitaplara sığdıramıyor
seher yeline söylüyor,
akıyor gözümden cu seher yeli,
seher yeli Ruhsati’nin derdini alıyor,
diyar diyar gezdiriyor,
mekanda gezdiriyor, zamanda gezdiriyor,
bu salona kadar getiriyor.
Güzel olan şu ki, bundan tam 150 yıl önce
dökülen o gözyaşı,
o gözyaşıyla şimdi
hepimiz gönlümüzü yıkıyoruz.
Arınıyoruz.
Gördüğünüz gibi bağlamanın bir yaşam
biçimi, felsefesi, derdi, kokusu var.
Kokusunu doğadan, derdini doğaya
yakın insanlardan alıyor.
Bu meseleyi ben öğrencilerimle paylaşmak
istediğimde şöyle bir şey
önermiştim onlara.
Bağlamayı doğanın bir yansıması
olarak düşünün.
Dolayısıyla bu sazı tanımak istiyorsanız
ağaca dokunmak zorundasınız.
Nitekim parmaklarından bal damlayan
aşıkların hiçbiri tabiattan kopuk değildi.
Fikri basit fakat uygulaması biraz
zahmetli gelmişti öğrencilerime.
Sonra bu fikirden bir soru çıktı.
Doğayı daha iyi tanıyan öğrencilere bu
fikri aşılasak nasıl bir sonuç çıkar diye.
İşte bu soru beni aldı çengeline taktı,
çocukluğuma kadar götürdü.
O hayallerini trenlere bırakan
çocukların köyleri.
Böylece Gezici Bağlama Atölyesi adı
altında bir çalışma başladı.
Adı üstünde Gezici Bağlama Atölyesi.
Yerimiz yok, yurdumuz yok,
masamız yok,
sıramız yok, okulumuz yok.
Paranın geçmediği göçebe usulü bir eğitim.
Öğrencilerimi aldım köy köy dolandık.
İki dinledik, bir kokladık.
Bazen bir aşıktan türkü dinledik.
Bazen bir nineden masal
çaldık, söyledik.
Nota okuduk,
bazen çelik çomak oynadık,
dağda çiçek topladık.
Kısacası doğanın emrindeyiz.
Doğa ne dediyse onu yaptık.
Şimdi bu dönemden bir fotoğraf
paylaşmak istiyorum sizlerle.
Bu fotoğrafın bende duygusal
bir karşılığı var.
Bakınca Hüseyin Orhan dedenin
gözünün yaşı aklıma geliyor.
Ruhsati’nin derdi.
Hatta Yunus’tan Veysel’e bütün ozanların
derdini düşünüyorum.
Sizce bu yaş, bu çimeni büyütmez mi?
Ne dersiniz?